das sind korn dogs aber nicht die
amerikanischen das sind koreanische
corners und die haben gerade mega den
hype auf tik tok ich ließ mir einfach
kommentare durch den viele schreibt herr
gut was soll daran besonders sein
würstchen mitteilt ich zeige euch wie
sie euch so gering dass sie extrem
lecker schmecken und halt dass ihr euch
überhaupt gelingen denn so einfach ist
das nicht aber mit der clique garantie
gelingt es euch definitiv also lasst uns
direkt starten kommen
[Musik]
also ich starte jetzt zuallererst mit
einem teig bei korn docs beziehungsweise
bei den koreanischen korn box kann man
entweder einen hefeteig machen oder ein
teig der erinnert so ein bisschen
pancakes teig und den mache ich heute
also heute gibt es kein hefeteig bei mir
und dafür nehme ich jetzt alle zutaten
gibt ihm eine schüssel und für sie da
und
leute ich schreibe euch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben und nun die chance
in die eu wolle sehr motiviert das
klasse
so alles rein alles verrühren und dann
geht es auch schon weiter
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier noch zwei kartoffeln
geschält und wehrt sie in ganz kleine
stücke schneiden das ist für meine
zweite corner variante denn ganz typisch
ist oft für die koreanischen korn dogs
dass man sie halt nicht nur in das punk
oder durch dieses pankow paniermehl
paniert gott was war in deutsch und man
nimmt auch kartoffel stückchen aber die
sind so fein dass man sie tatsächlich
noch eine minute oder zwei vorgang muss
und dann werden sie weiter verwertet
[Musik]
die kartoffeln habe ich jetzt abgegossen
das hat übrigens ungefähr zweieinhalb
minuten bei mir gebraucht ihr müsst halt
schauen dass sie nicht zu weich werden
sie sollen ruhig noch bis haben aber wir
wollen sie auch nicht roh frittieren
weil sonst beißt man auch später auf in
die heilbronner kartoffeln und dass ich
nicht so geil so und jetzt gebe ich hier
meinen frittiert in so eine flachere
schüssel dann können wir das gleich
einfacher darin wälzen und ihr seht
schon der ist schon sehr klebrig aber
genau so muss er sein und eigentlich
habe ich das meiste ja jetzt schon
erledigt ist auch superschnelles rezept
ist jetzt gleich nur noch aufgespießt da
habe ich hier so scharf stick spies wenn
irgendwie dickere spiesse haben nimmt
das gern ich glaube ich nehme es jeweils
zwei auf einmal damit einfach ein
bisschen sicherer ist und dann nehme ich
mir geflügel würstchen und mozzarella
und dann einfach ausschließen und in dem
teich hier wälzen
[Musik]
ich habe schon angefangen bei den ersten
kontakt zu frittieren und die sehen
einfach richtig gut ich freue mich
richtig auf den test ihr müsst darauf
achten dass der teig der ist schon sehr
klebrig und wenn ihr dann mach ich
übrigens die kartoffel variante deshalb
gerade habe ich die hälfte noch mit
mozzarella aufgespießt jetzt nur
würstchen weil zeit die kartoffel
variante kommt und er geht jetzt in den
teig rein und dreht dann praktisch immer
und durch das drehen haftet der klebrige
tag ein bisschen besser jetzt am
würstchen und was ich auch immer mache
ich nehme einfach noch mal so ein löffel
zu hilfe und gehe dann wirklich einmal
drumherum und dann sollte das eigentlich
auch funktionieren und jetzt das ganze
nicht im normalen paniermehl wälzen
sondern wenn in pankow paniermehl ist
next level pankow paniermehl ist einfach
so viel besser finde ich als normales
paniermehl also punkrocker nehmen müsst
euch vorstellen ist halt so ein bisschen
knuspriger und auch nachdem frittieren
habt ihr einfach so ein bisschen gröbere
stücke statt bei dem normalen paneele
was man so kennt und das findet ihr auch
in jedem supermarkt weile jetzt welt
sich das da einmal drin und danach
kommen die kartoffeln einfach nochmal on
top ihr könnt entweder so richtig in die
kartoffel so den spieß in die kartoffeln
schmeißen wälzen oder ihr nehmt euch
einfach in die hand und drückt es an ich
muss selbst noch gucken welche technik
die bessere ist aber so funktioniert es
eigentlich ganz gut es muss ja nicht
komplett mit kartoffeln umhüllt seinen
ganz im gegenteil es sollen einfach nur
ein paar kartoffeln stückchen dann
haften bleiben und damit das ganze in
frittierfett frittiert von jeder seite
so circa ein bis eineinhalb minuten
[Musik]
übrigens gab es jetzt mal andersrum
probiert um das funktioniert tatsächlich
besser also erst in den teig dann in die
kartoffeln dann kann man das nämlich
auch schon wälzen und dann in pankow
pandemie so und jetzt kommt es uns fett
und ich habe das gefühl dass die
tatsächlich pro seite ist eine halbe
million länger brauchen sie müssen halt
einfach richtig schön goldbraun seien
dann wenden dann sind sie fertig sondern
haben sie es übrigens auch da der macht
nebenbei fertigt
ein praktikant hier ja eine disco der
wahl noch ein deutscher ort man
zwischendurch ja aber nicht
[Musik]
fertig sind die koreanischen korn dort
gesehen so gut aus also hier richtig
hunger leute wenn ich ganz ehrlich zu
euch wäre es noch dekorieren mit mayo
und ketchup wir können auch sehr
angenehm aber ich ihr wisst ja ich kann
halt nicht mit dem scharfen und wenn ich
jetzt mal quasi so aufspritzen würde ich
zeige euch das mal dann kommen die also
kommt die wirklich dicken streifen und
wenn wir uns schon die mühe machen und
so supersüß und hübsche korn was machen
dann habe ich mir überlegt wenn ich sie
jetzt auch einen spritzbeutel füllen und
halt auch so typisch für ihren style
dekorieren und dafür einfach gefahren
die spitze abgeschnitten und dafür nehme
ich einfach herzlich
und macht die im gestell linien drauf
und es ist mein effekt so nein das ist
kein feld das ist so gewollt das haben
wir extra so gemacht dass diese
schlangenlinien da drin sind und das ist
auch gut so jetzt kommt noch ketchup
obendrauf ich bin trinke ich süß vor
allem jetzt mit ketchup und mayo
zusammen hammer
[Musik]
das
hat auch geklappt was auch immer
haben sage
so hast du gesagt wir probieren ich habe
das gemacht einmal mit kartoffeln noch
mal wo die sind ohne kartoffeln
koreanische kontakt royal coal ja ist ja
gerade richtig in ja
das ist mit kartoffel jetzt baut das ist
in katar von porsche kann es noch rein
dürfen diese und so ein paar so sicher
so druck machen
in einer darauf gewesen nach ketchup und
mayo drauf das würgespiel so richtig mit
als bis zum dritten reich also ich habe
mir jetzt hast du so einen bock drauf
bank übernehme nächsten level schmidt so
gut ist das mega sucht nutzt ja meine
kristic bei dex habe ich auch damit
gemacht das ist heftig richtig lücke
nicht bestätigen hat aber alles was so
kritische slacker ist soll ich so
gewohnt ja ich war heute jetzt nur noch
hits schreiben speziell aber es ist so
schlimm also man kann man sicher können
das ist echt ne genau also wir haben ist
natürlich jetzt noch drei findet schon
mal fotos und so weiter gemacht wenn ist
ja noch wahr ist dann
gucken wir das mit kartons motorräder
jetzt das ist mir daher weist ihr euch
ein erstes mozzarella und dann kommt
unten das wäre das hier ist direkt dass
wir jetzt hier in und mit dem käse
abgekühlt habe ich mir okay für die so
dem oder käse lieben das und für die dir
gewisse tricks sind das wort und will
davon nicht betroffen
kartoffeln finde ich auch gerne das ist
halt noch mal so was sowas überreichten
das richtig heftig leute macht es nach
ihr wollt auch nicht viele zutaten und
auch gar nicht viel also gar keinen
richtigen equipment dafür ich hab auch
keine fritteuse ich mache noch bei mir
meine von der forschen und zu sind auch
so sieht heftig auch aus oder sowas oder
rücktritte schön ja mach doch mal
überraschen daraufhin hat die für viele
leute überrascht um eure freunde damit
ist ja so schön danke danke also ich
habe ich mir gesagt die ganz genauen
zutaten die eier angaben in den von box-
und macht ja dafür macht macht einfach
machen macht ja also also was ich da
heute drauf
ist rené estermann aktuellen chips
gesellschaft so gemacht ja nicht
verändern meint wird es war cool ist das
halt so schwung reingebracht okay
halt stopp eine sache problemen raus das
habe ich auch gesehen zucker und ob ich
es manchmal denkst dir beim
verrücktesten sachen wie soll das
schmecken und probierst du und denkst
dir so
im ersten moment richtigkeit und im
zweiten moment
herrscht
auch
einigkeit nicht zuordnen
das geschmacksmuster nacht ohnmacht zone
ohne zugriff besser wusste ich sagen
[Musik]